[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Hi, everyone.
Welcome back to those of you
who were here this morning.
And if anybody is
joining us new,
you missed a really
great morning--
so, sorry.
And one of the things
you might have missed
was an incredible
introductory poem invocation
from our Barnstable
High School student
over here, Ceili Magnus.
[APPLAUSE]
Maybe encore at the end.
What do we think?
Encore at the end?
Yeah, OK.
- [INAUDIBLE]
- Yes, yes, encore at the end.
I am serious, at the end.
So just practice.
But meanwhile, you can
read it for yourself.
So I just wanted to point
out that for anybody
who missed them in
the poster session,
there were copies of the poem
that you heard this morning.
And there's going to be some
extra ones, because we ran out,
at the coffee break downstairs.
And then just so that
you don't forget,
if you stay through
the whole afternoon,
and it won't be too
long, and it will
be just as great as
the fantastic morning,
then you get to go to the
reception, which is, again,
with the posters.
So you'll have another chance
to think about education
and to have some lovely snacks.
So now, if you
remember, we had life.
We had earth.
And we had space.
So we're up to earth.
And we actually have a
discussant, Conevery Valencius,
whose name I can never say
right on the first try,
even though we've known each
other for quite a while.
And Nate Hultman
will be our speaker.
And let me just tell
you a little bit
about each of them, because
we're going to let Nate talk.
And then Conevery is going
to guide a discussion,
and then again, the floor will
be opened up for questions
from the audience.
So Conevery and I met when
we were Radcliffe Fellows
a couple of years ago.
And I was very confused
as to whether or not
she was a scientist,
a historian,
a historian of science, or
just an incredibly interesting
person.
And she's actually
all of those things.
So she is a Professor
at Boston College.
And she studies
Environmental History,
the History of
Science in Medicine,
American Energy, and
the US Civil War.
It's a very normal combination.
And so you can, as
I said this morning,
you can read her full
bio in the program.
And I'll just point out
that she is an alum.
Her PhD is from Harvard
in the History of Science.
We have many alums here today,
and if I pointed them all out,
I would take too
much time, sorry.
And Nate Hultman, who is
our first speaker today,
is currently the Director
of the Center for Global
Sustainability and an
Associate Professor
at the University of Maryland,
School of Public Policy.
And you may have
noticed in the program,
or you may have
noticed from his work
that Nate also was
in the White House--
not the current White House.
He was there from 2014 to 2016.
And his specialty is
climate and energy policy.
So again, 2014 to 2016.
And anyway, he's
going to talk to us
about the role of the
undiscovered in his subject
areas.
And then as I
mentioned, Conevery
will have a discussion with him.
And then it will be
open to the audience.
So thank you.
And take it away, Nate.
[APPLAUSE]
- So this is a symposium
about the undiscovered,
what we don't know.
And we've heard
a couple of talks
this morning that
elaborate on the concept,
and that have provided
us a couple of really
exciting examples of
how in science, thinking
about technology, we can expand
the way we look at things,
and think new, different
thoughts about what
might be out there.
But unfortunately when it
comes to climate change,
there is a ghastly
certainty in the science
of what we know about
the climate changes
that the planet will
witness in absence
of a dramatic, near-term action
to retool our global economy.
It's a message that
none of us want to hear.
But it is the clear-eyed
reality of our situation.
This is a graphic representation
of global temperature changes
from 1880 to 2015.
It provides a
striking illustration
of the increase of
temperatures over time,
and the accelerating pace of
new high-temperature records.
Of course, climate change
is more complex than this.
It's not just temperatures.
And we've been studying,
as a scientific community
and certainly in broader
communities such as my own
in policy, trying to think about
how to capture and understand
some of the problems inherent in
climate change for many decades
now.
A few weeks ago, this
knowledge was synthesized
in a report released by
the Intergovernmental Panel
on Climate Change, which
I suspect many of you
at least have heard about.
This report synthesized
thousands of papers
on our scientific understanding
of the likely impacts
of climate change under
different levels of warming.
The report concludes
that even an additional 1
degree of warming from
where we are today, by 2030
could expose hundreds
of millions of people
to dangerous climate
risks, stemming
from extreme temperatures,
floods, rising sea
levels, and more.
It would endanger ecosystems
and threaten species
with extinction.
It would likely wipe out
99% of the remaining coral
reefs on our planet.
And that is for 1 additional
degree from today,
to warming of roughly 2 degrees
above pre-industrial levels.
Without rapid new action,
we could be on course
to a warming of up
to 4 degrees Celsius
above pre-industrial
levels, with which
is a change that is
similar in magnitude
to the difference between
the depths of the last Ice
Age and today.
And we know all this with
significant confidence.
In fact, most of the scientific
unknowns-- most, but not all--
cut the wrong way.
Do we have less time?
Are we underestimating
the important feedbacks
or tipping points?
And might it be more severe
than we've thought up to now?
The report also assessed
what social and technological
transitions would be needed to
avoid these severe outcomes,
and asserts that a
window is open just
to keep warming to
roughly 1 and 1/2 degrees
above pre-industrial levels.
In a way, that is good news--
in a way.
But the sobering message is also
that radical transformations
need to happen in our
energy and social systems
on a very, very short timeline.
That timeline is
about a dozen years.
By 2030, 12 years
from now, we need
to have reduced global CO2
emissions by roughly 60%
from today's levels,
and to reach roughly
zero net carbon emissions by
2050, or 32 years from today.
And while that transition
is already underway,
I'm reminded of the
Marie Curie quote
about we don't look
at what's behind us.
We always look at
what's in front of us.
We are already on
the transition path.
That transition is happening.
And I'll return to that later.
But nevertheless, it
needs to accelerate
at an unprecedented scale and
pace from where we are today.
So that brings up this
undiscovered question,
of can we do it?
First, let's get
a sense for what
that scale and
pace of reductions
really might look like.
The left figure here is
actually from that IPCC report.
It's a schematic diagram,
which is sort of cartoonish.
But what you see on the
left is from roughly 1970
to 2020, the path of current
global emissions, followed
by two simplified pathways to
reaching zero net emissions
by mid-century, which is, again,
what we know we'll need to do.
The rapidity of
those changes should
be obvious from just
looking at the chart.
The table on the right
provides some rough guidelines,
or some rough estimates,
for the degree of change
we need to see between
now and 2030 and 2050.
Take coal, for example--
coal use needs to decrease
by roughly 60% to 80%
by 2030, and by
nearly 100% by 2050.
We need roughly
60% of electricity
to come from renewables by 2030.
And in some scenarios,
we would need well
in excess of 500
billion tons of CO2
to be captured and
stored underground
between now and 2100, using
a technology that has not yet
been deployed at
any kind of scale.
So clearly, we're
talking at nothing
less than complete
shutdown of the fossil fuel
system in the world's economy
over the next roughly 30 years.
It is a daunting task.
But like any task, we can take
some steps to ask what we know
and what we don't know about
what that transition might
look like.
So we do have some idea
of what needs to happen
and what that might look like.
It turns out that
such transitions
have been studied for decades
now by modelers, policymakers,
scientists, technology
experts, and many others.
And there are a few
consistent features
across almost all scenarios
that keep climate change
to minimum levels.
So first, you can see
here on energy system,
you use less energy.
That's energy efficiency.
That's a core pillar
of what we need to do,
so all the technologies
that use less energy
and use it more
efficiently are core
and central to this
particular one.
The second piece
is you decarbonize
all of our electricity.
In other words, take all of the
electricity we generate now,
and make it from renewable or
clean sources of some kind--
no carbon-emitting sources.
And then finally, you
look at anything possible
that you can use
electricity to do,
and you switch over from
fossil fuels to electricity
for all those applications.
So those are the pillars
on the energy side.
And then there's a
few other things.
You have to think about how to
absorb carbon in land sinks.
And to some degree, oceans
might be part of this, as well.
You have to think about
carbon removal technologies,
maybe in other words, negative
emissions from the atmosphere,
removing them using energy, and
sequestering them underground.
And then thinking-- and this
is where some creativity comes
in--
thinking about where we
can make substitutions.
What can we do differently
about how we organize our lives
and our societies
that can change
the practices from one sort
of technological strategy
to another?
And this I actually was
inspired by the keynote speech
there, where we heard
about the debacle,
the breaking up,
where you break it up.
And you reorganize
the pieces, and you
think about things
that are different.
So I'll return to
that in a later slide.
So we do have an idea
of what needs to happen.
These are some characteristics
about the coming transition
that we are pretty
confident about.
What we're not sure about
is how we operationalize
the rapid pace of
reductions with what
I would call the gummy,
imperfect, and sometimes
intractable social
systems that we have.
In, part, some of
that's unknowable.
But in part, we can look
to some other examples
to give us some ideas.
So I'll review some perspectives
on transitions of the past,
and what we know
about the transition
that we might need to undertake,
to see if we can eliminate both
what might be possible, and then
how we might organize ourselves
to go about doing it.
So I'm going to say four
different points on this.
So first, there have been rapid
transitions in technologies
before.
So we all understand the
concept of it used to be,
generally horse and
carriage, and we're now
using automobiles.
So transition in technologies
is a fundamental issue.
And we know that those
transitions happen more
quickly, or can happen quickly.
This particular
figure shows a number
of different technological
transitions in the United
States from 1880 all
the way up to 2010.
And you don't need to
spend a lot of time looking
at each individual curve,
but the concept here
is that this shows a curve
showing early adopters, all
the way up to kind
of essentially
full deployment
in the US economy,
by percentage of households.
And you can see on the left
side, you have telephones,
electricity.
On the right side, you
have things like cell phone
and the internet.
So what we're
seeing, first of all,
is that technologies
do transition.
And the question is, can
we make that transition
happen more quickly?
So let me ask a question.
How many of you in this
room own a smartphone?
OK, I should ask how
many don't, but OK.
So the point is, how many of
you remember that in June 2007,
there was no such thing
as an app or an iPhone?
OK.
And this is where we are today.
So that's a familiar
example to many of you.
Roughly 66% of
people in the US now
own a smartphone, 36%
of people globally.
Here's another
example-- automobiles,
I mentioned before.
Here's a picture of New
York, Fifth Avenue in 1900.
If you see, there's
a little red circle
around the single automobile
on the street at that time.
All the rest are
horse-drawn carriages.
13 years later, this is the
same scene, to the day--
essentially 100%
penetration of automobiles
in that particular
part of the world.
Now, that's one
It's not indicative
of the whole country.
For the whole country, it
went from roughly 1% in 1900
to 99% automobiles by 1930.
And this happens across
a lot of different kinds
of technologies.
There have been rapid
transitions before.
One you might not
be familiar with,
because it happened in
Brazil, was a transition
from traditional
vehicles to vehicles
that can use either
ethanol or gasoline, called
flex-fuel vehicles.
That particular transition
happened in the 2000s--
roughly 5% of sales in 2003
to over 90% of sales in 2009--
five years to kind
of essentially almost
full deployment on
the sales front.
So the point there is that
we can see rapid transitions
in technologies.
I should caveat-- these
are all contingent.
They're all specific to
the local circumstances.
They have a lot of
contingencies as to whether they
can work or not.
We have to think about how
those really worked in practice,
and think about how we can
apply it into the future.
I'm not saying it's just
going to magically happen.
Second on the
transition perspectives,
we have had broad
mobilization before.
And in fact, that IPCC report
calls out one specific example,
which many of you
were probably thinking
about when I use the
term "mobilization,"
which is World War II.
So in World War II,
defense expenditure
rose from roughly $2
billion in 1940 to $91
billion four years later.
That increase is equivalent to
$1 trillion in current dollars,
in four years.
The US produced about 40%
of the world's armaments
over that time, including
300,000 airplanes, 100,000
ships, and much, much more.
And we increased our
workforce by 7.7,
almost 8 million people.
People that hadn't been
in the civilian workforce
before had entered the
civilian workforce.
And you can see
an example of one
of those people in
the poster here--
obviously, an icon for
the fact that women
were moving much more
broadly into the workforce.
So that's an example.
It's called out even
by the IPCC report.
We know that happened
in one specific country,
under one specific
set of circumstances.
We know that that
level of mobilization
will likely have to happen
over the next 15 years.
So the real question
is, how can we do that?
How can we make that
happen on a global scale?
The third perspective
I want to share on this
is tying back to
the theme of today,
which is that our thinking
has often been wrong.
And we learn from it, but
it has often been wrong.
I'm going to give
just two examples,
although there are many.
There are many here.
Think back to the 1970s.
The middle of the 1970s,
there was an oil crisis.
There were a lot of smart
people trying to figure out
what energy demand would look
like in the United States,
to try to plan for it.
This figure shows a number
of different forecasts
from that period
of energy demand.
I don't know if you
can see the scale.
It's 1975 to 2000 was
the projection period.
And like I said, a lot of the
smartest people, so we think,
were doing these projections.
So if you are
looking at this, you
might say, well, OK, probably
somewhere in the middle.
What the actual
amount of demand was,
was at the very bottom
end of that envelope.
In other words, the economy
did much better on efficiency
than people had anticipated.
So people, in aggregate,
were quite wrong about where
we were headed.
And they were wrong--
in some way, we kind
of came out better
than people thought
at that point.
Here's another example.
This one's a little
harder to follow.
But what I want
you to see here is
that this is a set
of solar forecasts
over a period of
roughly 10 years
from a single organization, the
International Energy Agency.
Of course, we presume
that people would--
we're certainly much
smarter now, of course.
We have better models,
and all these things.
We've learned from our mistakes.
But what this shows is
that we actually didn't.
Each of those colored
bars shows a forecast
from a subsequent year.
So the forecast started
out very low for what
solar would look like.
And they increasingly
got higher.
And if you see the
dotted line there,
the dotted line at the very
upper end of that envelope
is where solar deployment
actually happened.
So the solar deployment
was way faster, way faster
than the International
Energy Agency predicted.
So each of these years
the forecasts increased.
And they were always lagging
by a significant amount
from where reality really was--
so very far behind in terms of
thinking about solar deployment
globally.
And by the way,
it's not just IEA.
There have been studies of this.
There's been lots of
other organizations made
the same error in judgment.
So the point there is that when
we think about the future, when
we think about what's
possible, we often
think about kind of
drawing extrapolations
from where we were
today, and not
thinking about what can happen
under different circumstances.
This has happened in energy
demand, as I just showed.
It's happened in eVs.
It's happened in photovoltaics.
It's happened in wind, and
it's happened in batteries,
among many others, that
we've been surprised
by the rate of change, even
with smart people thinking
about where it might
actually end up.
The fourth piece
I want to mention
is that we are
actually, right now,
in the middle of a
revolution in clean energy.
We need to be aware of that.
We need to acknowledge
that's what's happening,
and be open to that.
I use the word
"revolution" not fliply.
I think it's actually
really important
that we're considering what
the implications of that are.
But it actually is happening.
Currently, onshore wind or
traditional wind turbines
are one of the most competitive
sources for new generation,
coming in at roughly
$0.03 a kilowatt-hour.
That's at the very low end
of what fossil can generate.
Solar photovoltaic, as I
mentioned in the earlier slide,
has been quite surprising
over the last decade.
The figure here shows
a longer term decrease
from 1975 to 2007 in
the orange on price,
and a corresponding
dramatic increase
of photovoltaic deployment on
the right in the bluish color.
Costs have fallen 73%, roughly
80% over the last decade.
Over the last six
years, more money
was invested in renewable
energy than has been invested
in new fossil generation.
So that's a significant outcome.
$280 billion last year
was invested in renewables
globally, outstripping
the amount
we spent on all fossil
generation investments.
And finally, the international
Renewable Energy Agency
does estimate, with all the
cost drops we're seeing,
that renewable energy
will consistently
be cheaper than
most fossil fuels
in every part of
the world by 2020.
So for new generation,
we have the opportunities
to deploy these new
kinds of technologies
without radical
thinking about, will we
have to pay tons more somehow,
in order to have this happen?
Now there are other
challenges technically
about deploying renewables at
fast scale and at rapid rates.
I don't want to minimize
those, but the point
is that we have the tools
right now at our disposal
to do a rapid deployment.
So those are some
observations from the past,
from the present,
about some perspectives
on what this transition
might look like.
But there are
still some elements
that we still don't
know what to do.
We don't know how
to go about it.
And I think we have to
be honest with ourselves
that we need to be thinking
creatively and differently
about some of this stuff.
The IPCC report that I
mentioned earlier does mention
that the rates of changes
that we do need to see
have occurred in the past.
So that's what I was
essentially reflecting to you,
within specific sectors,
within specific technologies,
within specific spatial context.
But there is no documented
historical precedent
for their scale.
So it's the scaling question
and the social organization
question that really
is at the heart
of this particular problem.
So this problem, I want to split
up into a couple of components.
In one of the earlier talks,
we heard about the fact
that there's individual
components of a system,
and then there's
a system thinking.
Part of the individual
components of our system
will, of course,
be the technologies
that we use to deliver
the services we need.
And we know that there
are many such technologies
at our fingertips right now.
Many of you will recognize a
number of electric vehicles.
These are existing
electric vehicles today.
We have batteries that we
can deploy, battery storage.
We have drone delivery.
Very importantly, we have drone
delivery of Domino's pizzas,
which is shown here.
We have autonomous vehicles,
which are increasingly
being tested and
deployed, and will likely
be deployed at scale and in
the relatively near term.
We have offshore wind turbines.
Some of them are
anchored, some of them
are not, but increasingly
deployed globally.
We have magnetic
levitation trains
that have been demonstrated.
We have carbon capture
and sequestration,
which has been demonstrated
and commercialized.
And we even have-- and this is
one of the more different kinds
of technologies you
might think of--
meatless burgers,
which could, in fact,
be a significant contributor to
the change in carbon emissions
from our agricultural sector.
We also have technologies that--
there's not a bright
line between these,
but that kind of are
concept technologies.
We have technologies
that we can actually
use to suck CO2 out
of the atmosphere
and sequester it in the
ground or in solid materials.
We have Elon Musk's Hyperloop,
which I'm sure some of you
have read about.
We have small, modular
nuclear reactors,
which might be
proliferation-resistant ways
to get low-carbon energy.
We also have the ever possible
option of nuclear fusion, which
people continue to
work on, and may well
come through one of
these days, but is not--
it could happen.
And then finally, we have our
familiar unknown unknowns.
So in technology,
as you all know,
there's always discoveries.
We're always finding new things.
Many of those things
are hard to predict
from where we stand today, that
may still make a big difference
in, say, 2030 or 2040.
And that's one area
where many of you,
particularly I'm looking at the
young people in the audience,
might be able, with your
scientific inquiries
or scientific interests
or technological skills
that you're building right
now, be able to kind of grab
on to some idea
that you might have,
and make that into
a reality that
really does help the world.
But like I said, it is
not just the technologies.
The technologies are
a piece of the puzzle,
but they're not the system.
So we have to think about the
broader systemic approaches
that we can take,
reorganizing ourselves.
Reorganizing ourselves--
that mobilization
which includes technology,
but also includes
organizations, governance,
personal choices, and more.
And this is where we
have to be creative.
And this is, in some ways,
where it is somewhat unknown.
This is a diagrammatic depiction
of blockchain, which some
of you may be familiar with.
But people have talked
about blockchain as a way
that we can essentially use
distributed energy sources
and distributed storage within
the context of a smart grid,
which is the diagram
on the right,
to actually build out these
technologies on a much more
rapid pace, and allow people
to get paid for it as they go.
There's also food waste as
another way to think about.
Some people have
worked on food waste.
Food waste actually
accounts-- something
like a third of the food
that's produced globally today
is wasted.
It counts for something like 5%
to 7% of global GHG emissions
just from the waste.
So if there's a way that we
can reuse the food that we were
already throwing away,
or use less of it,
those kinds of
approaches are going
to be essentially important.
And then finally, one that's
probably more familiar
is retooling and rethinking
how we do our work,
and how we do our transportation
and living situations.
So can we telework?
Can we do other modes of
engaging with our workplaces,
but also with each other, that
ideally are more personally
fulfilling, less greenhouse
gas emissions, and also,
maybe, better for our health?
So we can track that
with the health tracker.
One example that I want to
give on organizing strategies,
we are now running an
experiment in the United States.
A year and a half
ago Donald Trump
announced his intent to
pull out of the Paris
Agreement on Climate Change.
Some of you may have heard
that when it happened.
Within 72 hours of that
announcement, a coalition
of 2,700 cities, states and
businesses stepped up to say,
we are still in.
We are still committed to the
goals of the Paris Agreement.
That group is called
We Are Still In.
And they've been
working with a group
that I'm affiliated with
called America's Pledge, led
by Michael Bloomberg
and Jerry Brown,
to think about how we can
organize ourselves differently
at different levels
of governance,
to accelerate what otherwise
would have happened
in this country.
So that coalition, which is
depicted graphically here,
is now over 3,500 strong.
It represents over
half the US population,
and it represents
almost 60% of US GDP.
So were it a country, it would
be the world's third largest
economy and the world's fourth
largest greenhouse gas emitter.
So I'm going to say two more
things about this topic.
The first one is that we
can choose our future.
The future that we
have is not just
sort of pain and suffering.
It's very much kind
of a positive story
of benefits and health.
So first of all,
there's an estimate
that we could benefit
by $26 trillion dollars
with this low-carbon investment.
Up to 150 million
premature deaths
avoided due to
reduced air pollution.
And finally, subsidy
reform in carbon pricing
that would put another
roughly $3 trillion
into government
revenues by 2030,
which is over the GDP of India.
So finally, the answer
is, can we do it?
And the answer is, yes, we
can under four specific kind
of possibilities.
First of all, to
improve the odds,
we have to think about
funding technology, R&D,
and fostering demand
with the private sector.
Second, we have to build
this into the economy
by investing in new
green infrastructure,
pricing carbon, and
disclosing risk.
We have to reorganize
ourselves, as I mentioned,
acting at all levels
of government,
using governance and policy as
a way to focus our responses.
And finally-- and this
is where I want to link
in to the earlier comments
that were made at the front end
of the session--
is to embrace our humanity.
This is a broad
economic opportunity,
but some people will
have to be displaced.
And so we have to
think about making sure
that the politics and
the transition strategy
works for all people,
and not just some.
And with that, I will conclude,
and say thanks very much.
And we can go to questions.
[APPLAUSE]
- Thank you.
Thank you so much.
And I think this is also
a good moment for us
to send a shout out to all
those watching on live stream,
because as we think
about creative ways
to replace travel, and
especially plane-driven travel,
with other forms of
virtual presence,
we need to get better at stuff
like, yeah, I'm going to log
into that conference now.
And the Radcliffe,
I think, has really
been leading the way on that.
So thank you.
I want to push us all now.
I don't know if I'll push Nate
so much, but I want to push us,
because this is a science
conference on the undiscovered.
And I want to talk a little
bit, or ask a bit about some
of the pieces that I
think can be undiscovered
in our conversations
about science policy.
I would like, very
briefly, for you--
us to talk to us about God.
And the room goes quiet.
Because that's what happens
in scientific discussions
when we ask about faith.
So you talked about
the need for--
that this is not
solely a science
question as it is
a scaling question
and a social
organization question.
Can you talk to
us about the ways
in which communities of faith
can, and are being mobilized
around climate change?
- Sure.
So first of all, it
is a great question.
I don't know if I can answer
the deep questions about God,
but I can say that your last
point about broader engagement
across different communities,
different organizations,
is going to be essential.
If we're thinking
about organizing our--
let me back up.
A lot of people have framed
up the climate question,
many times, as a question
of sort of consumer choice--
which is very
important, by the way.
It is important to choose green
energy, do all those things.
But it cannot be
just consumer choice.
We have to organize ourselves
to do these transitions
in a deliberate way.
And what we all have
right now-- somebody
earlier in the symposium
used the lovely term
"find your own tidepool."
So find your own way to use
the world that you're in,
use the sphere that you're in.
Try to think
creatively about what
can be done within that sphere.
And it's vitally important to
use those spheres that we're
already operating in
to maximize how we can
work with those communities.
And so the communities of
faith, the communities of--
I talked about cities,
states, and local governments.
That's one way to organize,
communities of faith
is another.
Universities is another.
You all can probably
think of many other ways
to kind of organize ourselves.
And long ago, the
climate question
moved from a science
and technology question
primarily to a question
of ethics, values,
and social organizing in action.
And that's where we are today.
It spans the spectrum.
And so the question for us is
sort of how do you link those,
how do you make the links
between all those dimensions?
And yes, I think making
sure we recognize
that there are deep
values in what choices
we're making over the
next couple of years
is an essential piece
of the answer here.
- OK.
Let's ask you one more,
and then we'll open it up.
So please be thinking.
Be brewing your excellent
questions, please.
So the crudest way I
would put my next question
is, so what makes this not
just a white people question?
And every time I talk about this
in an elite university context,
I think about that.
How do we open up, how do we
make the "we" really a "we?"
And you showed us a map
of the organizations that
are part of America's Pledge
and the We're Still In.
And that's a pretty
geographically spread-out map.
What are the ways in which
you see action that is useful,
that is moving the needle
on climate change, that
is geographically,
ethnically, socioeconomically
diverse and inclusive?
- It's a great question.
I don't have a
full answer to it,
because I think that's
actually something
that we need creativity and
energy to help us answer
collectively I do think
that part of the discussion
here has to focus on, again,
what are the actual benefits?
What are we actually getting
from this transition?
We are choosing in this,
I think, a better path.
We are choosing cleaner air.
We're choosing better health.
We're choosing more jobs.
And those kinds of
discussions are really
what ought to be
at the core of how
we discuss amongst ourselves
and discuss much more
broadly the benefits and
the strategies of doing
the transition.
- So here's where
we can go, not just
we need to eat our vegetables,
about giving things up.
Excellent.
Very nice.
I would like to
invite now people
to come up and ask a question.
A great writer once
wrote in a book
that I occasionally
wave at my students,
"Vigorous writing is concise."
I would add that so is
vigorous question asking.
So would you come up please.
And state your name.
And ask a question
of our speaker.
- I am Tanya [INAUDIBLE].
I am wondering if you
could also talk a little
about the role of
natural preservation
in helping slow
down climate change.
And that also seems to be the
appropriate last question,
that that would
also be something
that would help everyone
of any race or color
in the economic situation.
- Good.
The answer is absolutely.
There's a lot of reasons
to preserve natural areas
and to kind of encourage
continued growth
of those natural ecosystems.
Even in this country,
in the United States,
partly because of
climate change,
other reasons, we're
expecting some of, essentially,
the carbon sequestration
to be tapering off over
the next couple of decades,
without further kind of
conservation efforts.
So it's going to be
a key part of it.
And I think it can
happen in different ways
in different countries.
But it's got to be at the
core of how we approach it.
I agree.
Yes.
- Hi.
I'm Emily [INAUDIBLE] from
Barnstable High School.
And I have a question.
So we do so many movements,
like for instance the removing
plastic straws movement.
We try to bring about change.
But it always feels like
big businesses or business
practices in general kind
of try to suppress that when
they see the short-term profit,
or they see it as a problem.
So how do you think that
you will overcome that?
- I think that's part of
what we have to think about.
So there are individual
strategies that can be taken.
But as I mentioned in some
of my framing comments,
we're talking about a pretty
radical transformation
that a number of industries
will be directly affected by.
And so that strategy
has to include
the specific kinds of
targeted efforts like perhaps
you've been involved in.
And those are really
important to continue doing.
And I commend you for doing it.
On the other hand, it also
takes other kinds of social--
like when I talked about
organizing ourselves,
I do mean policy--
partly.
It's not the only thing, but
policy has to be part of this.
And then finally,
there's another piece
that I didn't really
address in the talk.
But that is about attitudes.
And you know attitudes can
also flip quite quickly
in our society.
And I think people study it.
But we still don't
understand all the drivers
behind what actually forces
attitudes to, or catalyzes
attitudes to change.
And that's something
where I'm hoping
you guys from Barnstable,
as you're doing your work
and you're grabbing
onto these issues,
you can help with that
shift in attitudes,
and with the energy and
the, hopefully, impatience
that you have about
getting something done.
- Get rid of plastic bags.
- There you go.
- And can I just
add that some of us
are old enough to remember when
any gathering of human beings
of this size, the room
would be completely filled
with a layer of cigarette smoke.
And that no longer occurs.
And that was a rapid shift.
So--
- My name is Kelly
Bowman, and I'm also
from Barnstable High School.
And my dad is someone who
kind of believes that climate
change isn't a serious issue.
He seems to think that nature
will balance itself out.
And I try to talk to him.
I'll share research
with him and data.
And he will tell me either that
I don't know what I'm saying,
or that I've been
brainwashed by liberals.
And so I was
wondering if you had
any advice on how I can talk
to him and people like him,
explain that it is a
serious issue, yeah.
- Once again, I thank you
guys for your persistence
and your energy.
It can be enervating
after a while.
So first, my last bullet, which
I had to run through a little
quickly--
I was a little over time--
the core thing
about this, I think,
is what I said in that
fourth bullet, which
is "embrace our humanity."
We do have to
remember that we're
dealing with other
people in our families.
We're dealing with other
people in our communities.
That doesn't mean
they're right, but that
does mean that we have
to deal sympathetically
and empathetically with them.
That's part of the answer.
But it won't get you there.
Sometimes, deployment
of more facts
is not going to actually
make a difference.
In fact, I would posit
that for those you who
have worked in
science policy, most
of the time,
deployment of new facts
doesn't actually
solve the problem.
What does help
sometimes is reframing
what you're doing, and
reframing why you're doing it.
And so I think thinking
about the economic benefits,
the positive future
that we can embrace--
I don't want to
overstretch the analogy,
but who is really
sorry that we don't
have hundreds and
hundreds of people
in each agricultural
field scything wheat
every season to bring it in?
We don't bemoan the
kind of transition
that we've gone through,
because people can do
other things more productively.
And they can do
interesting things.
And they can have a
better future, in a way.
So what we're talking about
is reframing the issue.
And maybe you could try that.
And maybe report back to us,
and let us know if it works.
- Thank you.
- Yeah.
- Hi.
I'm [INAUDIBLE],,
also from Barnstable.
My question is kind of similar
to Skyler's, in that you talked
about a rapid transition
in commodities,
like technology and automobiles.
But how do you propose to
initiate such a rapid change
for energy, when a lot of
people at the national level
just refuse to acknowledge the
existence of climate change?
- OK, good question.
- We're giving you the
really questions to answer.
- By the way, great for
all you Barnstable guys.
Great, great questions,
yeah, and your teacher, too.
So yeah, let's--
[APPLAUSE]
So a couple answers, and
I'll try to keep it short.
You guys know I like
to talk about this.
So first is right now,
the national level
is tough-- the next
year to two years.
We're just at a tough spot
at the national level.
We've got to go to
plan B right now.
And that's what we're doing
with America's Pledge.
It's what you guys
can do at Barnstable.
It's what all of us can
do on our own tidal pool,
so to speak.
So that's one of the strategies.
It turns out that strategy
builds the groundwork.
If we're deploying stuff
in our own spheres,
it makes it easier for national
reengagement down the road.
So that's part of a kind
of theory of the case here
of how that could be helpful.
But the other one is, frankly,
back to our attitudes question,
we have to recognize
and realize--
And your generation is going
to be a key part of this--
that we cannot burn
all those fossil fuels.
It just cannot happen.
right and I think we have
to be more overt and more
clear about the implications
of what we're talking about,
so that we can start getting
ourselves used to that
in the very near term, so
that when politics does end up
starting to shift, it shifts
in a way that reflects that.
- Thank you.
- Hi.
I'm Graciella.
I'm from Barnstable
High School, too.
So you mentioned initiatives
that national businesses
and governments can
take to make a change.
But what can regular people
do every day to make a change?
- Great question.
So again, it depends
on what your sphere is.
What choices do you have
authority over, so to speak.
So you have the
usual things of you
can bike more if you
have that option.
People have to think
carefully about this.
And I'm not trying to put
my foot down really hard.
But you can think
about your diet.
Think about changing,
reducing, at least,
the amount of red meat
that you eat, for example,
is one way to do it that you
can directly affect right now.
And then also, it is
very important-- again,
consumer choice is important--
if you can get your parents
to put in a
motion-sensing thermostat
or you buy an electric vehicle,
then great, and bless you.
But also, elections matter.
Politics matters.
Organizing matters.
And we have to use
our institutions.
We can't just do it
with consumer choice.
So do the consumer choice
stuff, and godspeed on that.
But also work in
these other ways.
And work vigorously
and with great effort
to make something happen.
- I'm Rachel, also
from Barnstable.
My question coincides with that.
Do you think that it's
possible that doing consumer
choice or a combination,
because you said
there are four ways that
you can go about it,
and combined together, that
will reduce it by a lot.
But say policy doesn't
end up swinging that way.
Is it possible to
reduce it the amount
that we need to
reduce it in 12 years
without policy or
something else?
- That is the undiscovered.
So I don't like to
say don't think so,
but I'll go back to the
second or third slide I did,
which is that just
incredibly rapid reduction.
The fact that we have
to get rid of 70% or 80%
of our coal-fired electricity
by 2030 globally is such a lift.
And I don't want people
to get the message--
sometimes this is like the
study of psychology of choice--
sometimes people feel
like when the job is
so big and so impossible,
they just back away.
And they're, like,
you know, I'm out.
I just don't see why
I can do anything.
We're done.
We are not done.
We're crossing the bridge.
We're part of it.
You saw those dropping costs.
So don't be discouraged.
But on the other hand, it's not
going to work without policy.
We're going to have to make
some changes in politics
to make this kind of thing work.
And it's not just to kind
of impose a carbon tax.
It's also to help
with transition.
There will be a lot of people
that could be displaced
by this rapid transition.
And we need to think
about, for example,
that kind of transition,
and making sure
that those people
are kept on board.
- Hi.
My Name's Casey Brown.
I'm also from Barnstable.
I had two questions today.
My first was, I
know that we rapidly
have to change to
more greener energies.
But what do we do with the
rest of the people that
have built their lives
and economy around coal,
or natural gas, or oil mining.
And my second is, I know that
we have to make this change,
but a lot of people won't
change unless it's appealing.
So how do you make being more
environmental more appealing?
- So those are two brilliant
observations and questions.
And by the way, all
these Barnstable
questions-- all brilliant.
So this is a wonderful
set of questions
you guys are bringing
up, and core to how
we think about this problem.
Very briefly, to the two
questions you raised,
one was on the people
that are affected.
And that's something--
there is now
a kind of emerging discussion
around what people are now
calling "just transition," so
thinking about those people who
are affected, and how
there is a kind of strategy
so that people who are, say, 45
and trained for a certain kind
of work might have options
beyond just working in the coal
industry.
So that's really important.
If you have ideas and thoughts,
apply your energy and thoughts
to how to help us there.
And then the second piece was--
what was the second one?
- Making it appealing.
- Making it
appealing, so again, I
had a slide at the end,
which was sort of fast.
But this is about a
set of better choices.
And I don't know
how many people have
driven an electric
vehicle versus driven
a regular vehicle.
And I can say with confidence
that electric vehicles are just
better cars.
They go faster.
They steer better.
There's less parts.
They're just better.
And what we're talking
about, in the long run,
is choosing those kinds
of better futures.
And I think that remembering--
I mean, a lot of my talk
was about the imperative
of doing it for this audience.
But as you're sort of
thinking about strategies,
and messaging, and engaging,
those positive stories are key.
So you're absolutely right.
- Thank you.
- Ricardo Cortez, and
I'm a grandparent--
- Are you from Barnstable?
- And I'm thinking about
my grandchildren, but also
the grandchildren in the world.
Because this is really about
them, and about you guys.
Based on the [INAUDIBLE]
graph that you have,
I would like to suggest that one
of the most important things,
perhaps, was left out of that.
And I think you just mentioned
it briefly, is that unless--
unless-- we leave 80% of fossil
fuels underground forever,
regardless what
we do, we're still
not going to be in good shape.
Thank you.
- Yes.
- Thank you.
- Hello.
I'm Andrew [INAUDIBLE] from
Barnstable High School.
Don't worry, I'm the last one.
I was just wondering,
will climate change just
slowly increment up?
Or will there be
a drastic change
that forces people to
all see it at once,
and that they can't
ignore it anymore?
And they'll have to
do something about it.
- Great question, and
one that scientists
have been really
struggling with.
There's two elements
of climate change.
One is sort of gradual
increase, with gradual sort
of increasing damages.
And there's another
dimension of sort
of tipping points or
extreme events that
get people to kind of wake up.
We really hope we don't
hit a major tipping
point in the Earth's system
in the next 25 or 50 years.
It's thought that the
risk of that happening
is relatively low
compared to those things
that we think are
more likely, like just
extreme heat events, flooding,
and sea level rise, et cetera.
But this is an area of--
I didn't spend a lot of time on
the science of climate change,
ironically for this forum.
But that is an area where people
continue to be actively engaged
in trying to understand.
So that's an area,
if you're interested,
is very important
to contribute to.
But right now, I think
it's important to remember,
we are actually living
it at the moment.
There are these events that are
unequivocally, or pretty much
obviously, driven
by climate change,
and that those are part of
what we're experiencing now.
Those were the predictions
that we had 20 years ago--
the droughts, the floods, the
fires, the intense hurricanes,
et cetera.
We are seeing the impacts
of climate change today.
So it's important
when you're speaking
with people about that to be
aware that that's actually
already affecting lives.
- Thank you.
- Jo Solid again.
I would like to turn to this
question that was raised
about communities of faith.
It has been explained
to me that there
are people who see
this potential climate
change apocalypse
as aligned with what
the future of humanity
is meant to be by God.
And they talk about
this as the Rapture--
that the world will collapse.
And the worthy will
be sent up to Heaven.
These folks don't
see a big incentive
to stopping that from
happening, because they
see themselves as worthy.
It's been described,
apparently, as part
of what goes on in Louisiana,
where you see the oil
companies destroying the
bayous, and the death
of the once highly valued
natural environment there.
And they accept this,
based on their beliefs.
How do we deal with that?
- But that's not just Louisiana.
I mean, this is a--
lot of different
opinions in Louisiana.
- I mean, look--
I actually don't have a great
answer to that one, either.
There is a point where you do
want to engage with people,
and be discussing in good faith.
On the other hand, it's also
possible to make the numbers
work on our side, so that
ultimately, there might--
some people might
never be convinced.
And I think we
have to kind of be
aware, in our social
systems, that we
have to continue to
kind of carry them along
with us, as we're trying
to make these transitions,
and do so in as empathetic and
constructive way as we can.
But there is a way in which--
engagement is good.
I think there are
people who are very
much in this
community of thinking
about the overlap between
ethics, values, faith,
and our choices in policy,
and environment, and climate.
And I wish them well.
It's not something
I directly do.
But other people do
that very eloquently.
I think, of, for example
Katharine Hayhoe,
who's a climate scientist-- and
you might want to look her up--
does a lot of
engagement like this,
with different faith communities
and the Christian faith
communities, particularly.
So there are people
like that who
can be advocates, who can
sort of bring the message out.
And I think the other
part of it is just
to continue to make that case
that this is a positive future
we're choosing.
It's not something
that should necessarily
lead to a worse outcome for
those people who are perhaps
not doing anything about it.
- There are groups
like Evangelicals
for Climate Action, for
instance, who are increasingly
finding their voice.
And I welcome now the last
question in this fabulous set
of questions.
- Excuse me.
Lee Goodman.
I'm a retired
transportation engineer.
I like to talk.
I'm very much in
favor of what we're
going to do in the future.
But what can we learn
from the present that
will help to change attitudes?
I'd like to know if there's
any research going on,
or if we're checking into
what's happening in Europe.
My perception is that there
are many countries in Europe
which are way ahead of us
in terms of renewable energy
policies.
France in particular, I think,
has a tremendous percentage
of its electricity generated
by nuclear right now.
Can we learn anything
from them in terms
of helping to accelerate
the transition?
- So it's a great point, and I
have two quick answers to that.
So first is, absolutely yes.
There are a number of countries.
There is lots of experiments
going on globally.
There's been a lot of
leadership from different parts
of the world in
renewable deployment.
We are kind of trying
to learn from those.
I think it's good to kind of
cross-fertilize with ideas
and policies and approaches that
have worked in other places,
and also learn from
what the failures were.
A second dimension
of your question,
that I think we can potentially
wrap on or leave off on,
we talked earlier in the
day about the connections
between some of the work
that's being done in science
and some work that's being done
in, say, humanities or social
science.
We even kicked off today with
some art, with the poetry.
And I think that this is an area
where making those connections,
thinking about what those
other disciplines can bring
to the table to help us
understand how we have
organized and how we
successfully organize ourselves
as human systems, as
cultural, social people--
how do we organize ourselves?
How do we motivate ourselves?
How do we kind of collectively
move in a certain direction?
That's something that a lot
of these other disciplines,
I think, have a lot to say.
And it was interesting in
reading that IPCC report,
it was very clear there wasn't
a lot of good literature yet
being brought to bear on that.
So there's a lot
of wide-open areas
for people to do research
and new inquiry on,
and to keep this
interdisciplinary conversation
going.
So I thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you all very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]